well the serial men who commit serial
sexual homicide which is what the public
usually is referring to when they talk
about serial killers as opposed to
nurses and doctors that kill patients
and hospitals
angels of death etc the the serial
killer like Ted Bundy and John Wayne
Gacy and David Parker rayon and those
people almost all of them more than 90%
meet criteria hard criteria for
psychopathy almost all of them are
sadists meaning that they meet criteria
for sadistic personality as it had been
described in the official psychiatric
manual where there's enjoyment of the
suffering of others as a key quality and
a love of control and domination of
others etc they're half of them are
loners men that can't make long
relationships with others so in fact
some of them use serial killing as a way
of having a one-night stand where they
rape and woman then kill her to destroy
evidence dumped her body by the side of
the road or whatever like Edie Kemper
out in California and then go on to the
next because they're incapable of a
sustained romantic intimate relationship
some of them seeking revenge revenge as
a motive and some of them like debarred
Laban and Texas who had been brutalized
by his father and his mother
so either constantly getting back at the
parents who abused them or neglected
them that would be true of Leonard lake
that had this torture place he built in
a remote area of California and the
another motive killing a specific parent
over and over but not not actually
killing the parent at for example when I
interviewed Tommy Lynn sells and death
row in Texas
he'd been neglected abused neglected
again by his mother never knew his
father
terrible terrible childhood and he went
around killing about 70 people most of
them women and when I asked him I said
Tommy you know it sounds to me like
maybe these women were like symbols or
duplicates of your mother did you ever
have a thought about you know killing
your mom and he told me says anyone
touched a hair of her head kill him in a
minute he only got one mom so that was a
very important point that I see over and
over in these men they have the same
kind of loyalty and love of a parent
even if the parent was abusive and
horrible that you can whip and hurt and
yell and scream at a child but if you're
the mom you're the dad that they're
still going to love you if they may they
may hate you as well but they're going
to love you so he never touched the hair
of his mother's head instead he did
symbolically get back at her through
these other murders
important question because there's no
one simple answer there are a few serial
killers six or seven in my very large
series who were adopted at Birth into
normal homes never abused never
neglected but who from adolescence on
became violent and then in their 20s
embarked on a career of serial sexual
homicide that you can only ascribe to
some genetic flaw along the lines of
deficits in the amygdala or the
prefrontal cortex that I had spoken
about Gerald Stano would be an example
of such a person who killed 40 women was
finally executed and in San Quentin
there are other men who were raised in
fairly good homes or even rather normal
homes but who suffered a head injury
that affected these key areas in the
frontal lobe such as Richard surrett and
George it was raised in a wealthy home
went around killing ten women after he
had married and he had a daughter but
then he got kind of fed up at the
marriage etc now he had suffered two
bouts of prolonged unconsciousness when
he fell from jungle gyms and things like
that when he was a kid after which he
underwent a dramatic and swift change in
his personality the same thing by the
way that happened to Phil Garino who was
a normal kid in a normal home but who
fell off his older brother's motorcycle
when he was 14 and within days he was
unconscious he had to have a brain
operation within days he began to
develop rape fantasies and then carried
out a number of rapes and finally
kidnapped that young Jaycee Dugard girl
that he kept for 18 years and had two
children by her now the thing there is
there are other areas of the brain in
the limbic system connected to the
frontal lobes and so on and involving
the temporal lobes on the side they have
to do with our sexual responsiveness
what we respond to sexually if those
areas are damaged we may end up with
pedophilia or abnormal desires for
inappropriate objects so
that clearly happened - to Phil Garrido
he became immediately fascinated and
eager to commit rape when he was 14 15
years old after the head injury so
there's a and about 30 percent of the
serial killers have experienced some
form of rather serious head injuries so
that's a that's a factor that not too
many people know about but that's
important also so the bulk of them
however have come from horrible homes
where the early damage and misery of
their home becomes a motivating force
later for seeking revenge against those
who had hurt them Plus which they have
also been raised in such a way that they
don't have the social skills in order to
kind of compensate for that and to make
a good relationship anyway and kind of
get past it
so they're stuck you're they're mired in
the misery of their childhood forever